foreign policy and war
well frankly on a personal level I'm not
a big fan of war
I think truthfully what will being
honest people they die they get very
dangerous they get very people get upset
countries don't really want to go to war
so if I can't I would avoid war but if
it's necessary it's a someone starts a
fight with Trump let's say someone comes
into the country through the board and
they have inside the guest book they
haven't talked to the doorman doorman by
the way is a Mexican at my place he
loves me he talks to the Mexican Prime
Minister president whatever you want to
call it and he tells me hey we love you
frankly we call you the Mexican man down
and down south of the border that's what
they called me frankly I never chosen it
day but that's what they called me so
when it comes to war I think that I
would I frankly I would handle it like
my Mexican doorman and frankly the
people doing the war would take my calls
they take my calls
click here to hear me answer your
questions about megyn kelly who frankly
I'm not a fan they don't call me the
megyn kelly Fed they call me the
opposite of that